-Our next guest is nominated
for four Grammy Awards,
including Best New Artist,
Best Rock Performance,
Best Rock Song, and
Best Alternative Music Album
for "Punisher,"
which is available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
Phoebe Bridgers.
Hi, Phoebe. How are you?
-I'm great. How are you?
-I'm great.
So this is your third time
technically on the show.
It's the first time
we're chatting.
You were in studio
with Boygenius in 2018.
Then you did a beautiful
film performance
for us during the pandemic
Is it different as an artist
being on a talk show,
one, where you get to
film it ahead of time
and the other
where you get to be in studio?
-Um, yeah, I --
I'm honestly going to be
so spoiled after all this
because I love the control
I actually -- When I was o
your show with Boygenius,
I yodeled really loud
on accident.
And, you know,
you can't go back and fix it
It was a nightmare.
So I like being able to listen
to mixes and make changes.
-Is an accidental yodel
something
that happens to you often
or was it just in the moment
-Yeah, I have the accidental
yodel when I hit high note
and then also an accidenta
Eddie Vedder
where if I hit a really loud
note sometimes I have like..
[ Growls ]
It's pretty rad.
-I will let you know
that I did not notice.
I only thought it was
a wonderful performance.
I'm wondering how weird it is.
You have this album,
and it receives
all of this praise
and these multiple
Grammy nominations,
and yet most of it
is happening at home for you
Has it been an even more surreal
year than it is for most peopl
because you would
have been so out and about
I would imagine,
on the back of this great album?
-Yes, it's so weird.
I hate that, like,
the only connection
I have to my friends
and the universe is online
Yeah, it feels super weird
Grocery store is where
I hang out. That's it.
-Another thing that seems --
I don't know --
"Fortuitous" seems
like the wrong word,
but, you know, again, this i
an album that was written,
recorded ahead of time,
but a lot of the issues,
you know, grief,
family relationships,
the world ending, are very muc
at the forefront of this album
How has that been to know
that you sort of wrote
the perfect album
for a very hard time?
-Yeah, I feel like
I'm always having a hard time.
So, I'm terrified of everything,
always think the world
is going to end.
So I think maybe
even if I released
my first record around now
people would have thought
it was about COVID,
but, weirdly,
I think, looking back,
I will remember
the record more from
when I released it
than when I wrote it.
It actually kind of does
remind me of isolation,
I think, 'cause I played
the songs so much in my bedroom.
-I've heard tell that your
neighbors are maybe not thrilled
with living next to a musician
who plays songs in her bedroom
Are they --
Have they changed their tune
at all based
on the success of the album?
-I have one cool neighbor,
Michael,
who says "what's up?" to me an
knows that I have a real job
but there's one neighbor
that tells me to shut up
and then my next next-door
neighbor plays slap bass,
so I feel like I'm suffering
from his slap bass.
Like, my acoustic guitar
whispering
after a whole day of slap bass
is just too much.
-Right.
You're the tipping point.
-Mm-hmm.
-Again, I do think
it's really important
to look at silver linings
over the course
of this last year,
and I will say I thought
it was really awesome and cool
to see you
on the cover of "Variety."
I don't know if you had told m
March 11th last year
that you were going to be
on the cover of "Variety" --
I would've been like, "Wow. What
kind of year is it going to be?"
So -- But somebody
got edited out of this photo
-Oh, my God. I know.
She really did.
[ Laughter ]
-So you -- you brought her
to the photo shoot,
and they took a bunch
with the dog, yes?
-Yes.
-And then they just iced her
-I know.
I think there's, like, a video
of us doing the photo shoo
that she's in it,
but she's super photogenic
so I don't understand.
She's just sleeping on my la
right now.
-Yeah, it must be, like,
a weird Zoom filter right no
because she looks
a little weird,
but obviously
she's an incredibly --
We can all tell she's
an incredibly beautiful dog.
Hey, one thing
that's really cool --
I would love to finish
with this -- is you
in the Best Rock category.
It's all female artists.
That's never happened before
It's such a neat thing
to be a part of.
Do you feel a connection
to the nominees?
I know people always say,
"Oh, it's so great
to be nominated with
this group of people,"
but maybe this year that's
even more true than normal
-Definitely, yeah.
I'm such a huge fan of everybody
who put out records,
especially in, like,
the alternative categories
I just feel like they're peopl
I would have been --
We call it "tour bidding" when
you're, like, on a festival tour
and you see the same peopl
every day
because everybody put out
a record at the same time.
So I feel like there are peopl
that I probably
would have gotten
pretty close with
because we all released musi
last year,
but being ripped away from that,
it's cool to have somethin
so awesome as the Grammys
bring us kind of closer.
-Also you released a cover
of a John Prine song,
"Summer's End,"
and one of the days
that I feel COVID
most became real to me,
because I was such a fan of his,
was when he passed away
in sort of the early part
of last spring.
And I'm assuming he was someon
that you're a fan of
for you to do a cover like that.
-Yeah, that was
the worst day ever.
It was just, you know --
He'd been struggling
with his health for a long time,
but he pulled through
and completely relearned
how to sing,
and I saw him in Oslo.
It was the weirdest.
I landed the first day of tour
walked out of the airport,
and saw this huge sign
that was like,
"John Prine Tonight."
And he represents
kind of the pinnacle
of, like, American music to me
So I saw him at this,
like, theater in Oslo,
and people
clapping very politely,
and he talked about American
politics and was so charming
And I've seen him a bunch,
but, yeah,
that was a very depressing day
and definitely one of
the reasons I chose it.
And he was nominated
for Best New Artist in 1972,
which is pretty cool.
-Well, that is a very nice way
to close this.
Thanks for doing that.
Thanks for the album.
And thanks for being here.
It's just a delight
to see you, Phoebe.
-Yeah, thanks so much, man
-"Punisher" is available now
We will be right back
with more "Late Night."